welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness's one division
connection just went from static to
clear signal
with kevin feige confirming doctor
strange was originally planned to appear
in the one division finale he's gonna be
the source of those never explained
commercials
but the cameo was removed causing a
rewrite to multiverse of madness and
most importantly helping debunked nerd
theorists like me
sleep again so you cut doctor strange
you cut the bunny turning into a hell
demon but you keep ralph boner okay
cool but these reveals actually tell us
a lot about how
the scarlet witch will return in
multiverse of madness and really
what was doctor strange's plan during
the events of one division
i'm gonna explain it all but spoiler
warning in case my theories are right
but if not i don't care because it's
more fun to be surprised so
kevin feige confirmed doctor strange was
going to appear in the wanavision finale
but was written out because he said they
didn't want to overshadow wanda's story
with a bigger name avenger stealing
focus
wanna vision head writer jack schaefer
revealed that the commercials were
planned to be messages from strange to
wanda
and that strange was going to appear in
one of those ads looking back the
commercials were one thing i actually
managed to theorize somewhat correctly
accurately predicting that the final ad
would be one for antidepressant
medication and wouldn't you know it it
was
but now that we know that these were all
messages from doctor strange that
changes so much about how we should
understand wandavision
in episode 4 we learned that everything
we had been seen
as part of wanda sitcom reality was
being broadcasted out on local
frequencies
being picked up on darcy's av equipment
and that includes the commercials
[Music]
the commercials were for the stark
industries toastmate 2000 the strucker
watch
hydra soaked bath soap lagos paper
towels yo magic yogurt for kids and
nexus antidepressants
actually right as one division began
feige was asked about these commercials
and he responded in some choice language
that was part of something early on
how are other truths of the show
beginning to leak out and commercials
were an early idea for that and if this
is the very first marvel mcu thing
you're watching it's just a strange
version of the 50s commercial or 60s
commercial that you have to keep
watching the series to understand
strange the answer was right there
all along the whole time but before i
continue thanks to keeps for sponsoring
this video
losing your hair can be a boomer
sometimes i'm over here pulling my hair
out trying to figure out these
theories and find all the easter eggs
but i don't want it to be falling out on
its own well two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35
i know guys in my life that are stressed
about it with keeps it's easier and more
affordable to get treatment for your
hair loss and to keep the hair that you
have keeps offers generic versions of
the only two fda approved hair loss
products out there but at half the cost
of your local pharmacy like you used to
have to go to the doctor's office for
this kind of treatment but with keeps
you can do it all from home you meet
with a doctor online and they ship the
treatment right to you every three
months so you don't have to wait in line
at the pharmacy
find out why keep says more five star
reviews than any of its competitors and
nearly 100 000 men trust keeps for their
hair loss prevention medication
so if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
new rockstars or click the link in the
description to receive 50
off your first order that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash new rockstars now episode
eight confirmed to the many theories
that the commercials were linking to
wanda's history like the mysterious red
colored beeping of the stark toaster was
indeed wanda's subconscious reminding
her of the stark bomb
that traumatized her in pietro
the strucker watch and hydra soak were
nods to her time with baron von strucker
in the hydra lab lagos paper towels
referenced her guilt for the casualty
she caused in lagos nigeria the
beginning of civil war but yo magic
yogurt and nexus antidepressant remained
a bit up for interpretation like sure
you could say they're reflections of
wanda's sorcery
and status as a nexus level being that's
the score of the witch nexus meaning a
marvel being that can detach oneself
from any one reality but the series
itself never explicitly confirmed that
intention
until now with this doctor strange
reveal the west view hex with its shifty
and sitcom aesthetic was mostly wanda's
doing of course but
other sorcerers could use their magic to
meddle within that hex agatha harkness
arrived after it began
and manipulated wanda within it trying
to steal her sorcery but doctor strange
was
also interfering via these commercials
his interrupted messages took the form
of classic television because
like everything in the hex wanda sorcery
warped strange's messages to fit the
broader aesthetic and the fact that
wanda trumped strange here is why agatha
told wanda
your power exceeds that of the sorcerer
supreme
doctor strange sensed the west view hex
the same way agatha did and his plan was
to awaken wanda from her hex by sending
her these messages
at key moments of cognition or
vulnerability in episode 1 it was the
confused phone call between wanda and
vision
that set up the whole second half of the
episode which led to strange sending the
message reminding wanda of her sokovian
origin
which is why wanda brings up her
circovian background right after this
in episode two dr strange saw that
moment dottie broke the glass and
antagonized wanda which broke
juana's reality for just a second
allowing strange to ping her with a
reminder of her time with strucker in
episode three the commercial comes right
after that scene with that awkward
internal jump cut
and when wanda's water breaking causes
it to rain inside at which point dr
strange comes in with the hydra soap
commercial in episode 5
strange comes in with the ad for lagos
paper towels right after wanda threatens
hayward and sword to stay out of west
view
warning wanda about the last time she
used her chaos magic to hurt people then
in episode 6 wanda suspects pietro as a
bad influence
and then shortly after strange's
commercial message is for yo magic
yogurt featuring a bro-y predator
calling the kid
little dude just like pietro does there
you go little dude
right on little dude this is a way of
strange telling wanda that the only way
for her to survive is to
use her magic which wanda does at the
end of this episode and then the final
commercial comes in episode 7 precisely
when wanda is shocked to hear the voice
of the director
which we later discover is agatha's
modulated voice behind the camera
and in that moment of cognition strange
comes in to tell wanda that she is
a nexus being but in this message he
includes this warning
you should not take nexus unless your
doctor has cleared you to move on with
your life
and as i suspected at the time the
doctor is dr strange i think
this was the commercial he was going to
appear in his message to wanda is to
wake up from the stream
and consult your doctor strange to
unleash your true potential now while
this was left out of one division feige
indicated
this cut meant rewrites to doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
so strange's attempts to contact wanda
inside the hex still might be mcu canon
and could get explored in that film
as the scarlet witch becomes the
antagonist of that story because in this
same article elizabeth olsen said that
wanda fled westview to a place
no one would find her because she knows
she's going to be held accountable and
in this post-credits scene it's now even
clearer how it ties in with multiverse
of madness doctor strange's music
[Music]
wanda using astral projection a move
used by doctor strange except
she's even more advanced because she
doesn't need to be asleep to do this
but notice the camera movement the
camera swoops in across the lake
never cutting as it glides into the
cabin and into the back room
as if seen from the unblinking point of
view of the ever watching sorcerer
supreme himself
so my friends doctor strange was not a
no-show in wanda vision
westview and wanda max moth were one of
his biggest failures
and as he has to face her in multiverse
of madness
when the scarlet witch reaches her nexus
potential i don't think she's gonna seek
a doctor's prescription not that anyone
will be able to read it anyway i mean
even for a doctor steve's handwriting is
terrible
support new rockstars by checking out
one of our many great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com like this
shirt you can you can get it you can be
me follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos subscribe to rockstars for
breakdowns of everything marvel thank
you for watching bye
[Music]
you